the next time you find yourself debating
what's the scariest horror movie you'll
potentially be able to have science to
support your claim that's thanks to the
hard work of the folks at the uk's
broadband choices who took time to use
the scientific method to determine the
scariest movie of all time their science
of scare project exposed a group of
viewers to some of horror's most iconic
films while researchers examined how
much each movie raised their individual
heart rates as proof of its power to
terrify
[Music]
as reported by several outlets in 2020
scott derrickson's profoundly disturbing
2012 creeper sinister was the first
horror flick to be crowned scariest of
all time the study was such a resounding
success broadband choices decided to run
it again in 2021 adding a handful of
recent releases to their screening list
sure enough one of those new films has
dethroned sinister as science's all-time
scariest and the film that took the
crown will likely surprise you
for reference the list of selected films
fronted such iconic titles as a
nightmare on elm street the texas
chainsaw massacre and the exorcist
alongside modern classics like the
descent the babadook and it's chapter
one those frightful films are all
currently looking up at the 2020 shutter
original host which science has
officially dubbed the scariest movie
ever made we're guessing some of you
maybe even most of you haven't seen or
haven't even heard of host should that
be the case you need to seek it out asap
it's an extraordinarily creepy little
film that gets under your skin in ways
few horror flicks do written and
directed by rob savage host clocks in at
a brisk 56 minutes in length and was
shot entirely during covert 19 lockdown
utilizing zoom video conferencing
software in that format host finds a
small group of friends attempting to
stay in touch during isolation with
weekly calls during which one of them
hires a medium to conduct an online
seance no spoilers but we'll just say
things quickly get creepy for the group
and that host is a supremely clever
legitimately terrifying piece of work
well worthy of that top spot as for the
other films on the list sinister
insidious the conjuring and hereditary
round out the top five in that order
with the likes of it follows a quiet
place part two and paranormal activity
or placing in the top ten
now you're the one who's afraid despite
the fact that science has crowned the
winner for the scariest movie of all
time there will always be others
convinced their point of view is the
right one it's true there are plenty of
other lists that insist other movies
deserve to dethrone host and of course
creative folks will come up with even
scarier stuff in the future imdb users
have ranked the scariest film of all
time as 1973 classic the exorcist
roughly 388 000 users have rated the
movie and it has earned 8.1 out of 10
stars on the site
that kind of rating doesn't come by
every day and even though the movie is
several decades old it still finds a way
to crawl under people's skin the
exorcist also tops the ranks from rotten
tomatoes where the site writes about the
flick
outside of its critical and commercial
bonafides the film is well known for the
mass hysteria it inspired across the
country from protests over its
controversial subject matter to
widespread reports of nausea and
fainting in the audience
that's not the only opinion floating
around online the guardian lists another
1973 horror movie don't look now as the
all-time scariest meanwhile movie web
bestows hijana to the blair witch
project in large part for reigniting the
interest in the found footage sub-genre
while host has science behind it it
always seems like a matter of opinion
when it comes to movie rankings online
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one